we've got some gusty winds out there and
they've already been blowing in some
neighborhoods
and alex i just have to let you know if
your trash day you better make sure you
know where your trash can is because
we're looking at some gusty winds
please neighbors be on the lookout for
alex's trash can today
because i have a feeling it's going to
roll down the street a little bit we're
looking at 25
30 to maybe 35 near 40 mile per hour
winds
and so alex's trash can she needs a
little help when she gets home today so
please help her out
i need all the help and my dog will
probably be running after it too
so we are looking at some really gusty
winds and they could be knocking trash
cans over
we get them up over 30 miles an hour
that's going to blow around some trash
in your neighborhood
and please hang on to the steering wheel
nate's coming up right right after me
with the look at the roads this morning
look how mild we are 60s and 50s around
the las vegas valley
now our biggest winds have been in the
mountains so far over
50 mile an hour winds up there at kyle
canyon and we're expecting those
downslope winds and we're getting them
this morning wind advisories go in
effect for everyone
in clark county except the moapa valley
and the far
northwest corner of clark county a
southern nye county
not included but we are looking at the
winds that are still going to be up over
30 miles an hour for many areas
mojave county arizona san bernardino
county all along i-15
included in that wind advisory as well
so a couple of systems approaching us
bringing cold fronts behind them will
cool down a little bit by tomorrow
today still looking a really mild day in
the upper 60s to near 70 degrees
and then by tomorrow we'll drop almost
10 degrees some neighborhoods may not
get out of the 50s for tomorrow
and then 30s tomorrow night so it will
be cooler and then we just warm up
steadily again right into super bowl
weekend beautiful mid 60s sunday
and then next week still in those mild
mid to upper 60s
mostly sunny skies wow feels like spring